now let me ask you a question uh about
your life which is are you able when you
when it's been a really tough news day
yeah and you're watching things go down
that maybe can worry you as a husband
and a father are you able to
go home and shake that off and say oh it
really depends I mean sometimes yes
um
I mean look most news is not good news
right most news is is negative in some
way or another
um
like some things are very distressing
obviously the the school shootings are
very upsetting uh war is very upsetting
you know January 6 was very upsetting
that sort of thing and it's tough it's
tough to shake it off
um
but generally speaking I go home and I
try to change the subject I try to yeah
just be with the kids and be with the
wife and not I don't watch news I'll
watch you or I'll watch uh other things
on streaming or whatever but like I'll
try not to watch any news when I go home
do you uh I mean
I guess Twitter has become a different
thing but uh it's really weird now isn't
it yeah are you on it like the algorithm
I got off I I couldn't yeah it's
interesting because I didn't go on it
that much but there are certain ways
where you can get the news and kind of a
straightforward way on Twitter and then
uh I felt like it started to change and
now I'm seeing a lot of stuff that just
really depresses me and I feel like I'm
uh a very heavy lens has been put in
front of me that's distorting the
picture I feel like there's an algorithm
that look all social media has this now
where they I mean they've all been doing
this for their exacerbating and making
us see conflict and hate and stuff like
that but I feel like this new
um
permutation of of Twitter is like it's
showing me things I don't want to see
like there's a whole I you know I have
the people I follow and I want to read
them but like it defaults to some other
group of tweets that like I don't who
would I don't want to watch I don't want
to read these tweets from these people
who are they right like they've added
this thing of like here are tweets that
we would like you to read as opposed to
this is what you this is what you would
like to read yeah from you know really
awful people and I don't know I mean
it's just strange to me but I'm sure he
knows what he's doing yeah yeah I think
that it's just all you see online is
extremes like the people in the middle
aren't really that active it's the
people who are extreme who are just just
talking about Twitter are you talking
about all social all of them all this
like when I go on Reddit I feel like
it's like sometimes it's very doomsy
well of course it's Reddit what are you
talking about but that's like when I go
into the dark web it takes a turn yes
can I just say even the pornography I
watch is very it's very doomsday it's
always like let's do it what's the point
we'll be dead soon and then
I watch listen I like to score on my own
pornography
everybody
you listen on mute and then you do the
music for it yeah
I like to mute the porn and then put my
own music in and voices
la la la
it sounded fast
here I go I've never heard one Chuck
like I've just never yeah
that's like a Beretta episode I thought
it was agreed upon that it was chica
oh nice last time you guys watched porn
1977. it's in the book yeah that was the
summer of porn
we are all except during the blackout
yeah when suddenly all the porn went
dark
that's the Block No when Elvis passed we
all had to do something to recover so we
watched four years old and of course
that foreign
I'm telling you this is all true it's
all in the book there's no porn in the
book no there's no point there is no
point
if you were to do porn music what would
it be it wouldn't be there would be no
music it's just the squishing sound okay
all right
what are they making latkes
before they have sex
this is not a squishy no that's a
clapping sound I know I can't squish
with my hands
we have a respected newsman here and
what's going on people rely on him
somebody stuff it's happening
and this is what you do with its owner
I'm going to take us down this road well
Gorly and I put beautiful music
pornography and then you come along with
your physical sounds your squishies
apparently you and your husband high
five each other during sex
because there's a squishing sound
that's just like we did it the Clippers
scored another hit
your babies are good though you said
come on why do you have to go to my
babies because well you because all of a
sudden we were talking about you having
sex
yes you had babies yes that's I know and
last time I did this podcast you were
about to have twins and you used I named
them Leopold and Loeb which was such a
fantastic yeah that's great I think
Leopold and love is the perfect name for
them Eric and Lyle any there's so many
there are so many killing Duos Saco and
Vanzetti Sato and venzetti well
were they guilty we don't know right fat
man and little boy yeah oh my god oh wow
oh my God those are the nuclear bombs
yes yes they are that's right that's
right well I don't know I mean why if
I'm just saying if one of her kids were
a little chubbier than the other one it
could be well yeah one's a little
thicker oh there you go there you go
that's great he's probably listening
right now and a single tier is going
down
Mama thinks I'm chunky